oh that's an old intro epic welcome back
crazy times what's happening 2020 be
like brah but we know there's one thing
you can always rely on no matter good
times no matter bad time epic meantime I
think the formula goes the worse things
are the better the memes really so let's
just jump in I like this this is good
because it doesn't mention anything hey
this could mean anything and I can still
say monetize thank you keep the memes
like that vague enough alright vague
enough uno the world's number one card
game number three so oh man I want to
see that scene in Japanese that'd be so
cool everything just sounds cooler in
Japanese simple things in life make me
happy it doesn't take a lot but Japanese
fan dub of episode three Star Wars that
make a smile on my face my dad telling
me that I'm adopted me calling him a
virgin did MA I'm just copy my freaking
style dude oh my god
how could he how do I look more bald
than when I'm growing the hair back it's
cuz this hair doesn't grow as fast I
mean it is I don't have any problem with
my hairline Thank You P P Creek PP Creek
well done well done lads you did it
congratulations
I feel like UK wins over America though
in bad names there it is
we got a P P Creek as well don't think
you're so goddamn it goddamn it it's in
America fine you win this round America
you win this round enjoy your pee pee
creek we don't want it
you watch Felix new minecraft vid he
forgot the bud son jr. he renamed him
deep he made her freak I didn't mean to
I can't believe a I can't believe it
could you stop trying to kill us for
five minutes
good job subtle enough that I can meme
it Thank You Shrek I appreciate it I
have walked across the surface of the
Sun I've witnessed a man turned himself
in to pick up it was the funniest I will
ever see I love this meme it's so good
therapist why you said I will never
experience anything more hilarious than
the man that turned into himself into
Pickle petition to name the new dog
Alabama your wish is my command I did it
I did it already he belongs in hell so I
guess that means Sweet Home Alabama is
in hell who would have thought scarred
amazing fanart spine apples very good
very good I like this a lot it's a tough
job but I swear I pay her well nothing
she gets nothing facts facts facts okay
this is again it's bullying this is
bullying stop the bullying the lovely
spend family all right we have spent
okay sense boyfriend look this poor soul
is the offspring of Sven in his zone yes
you made Sven
Frick his son he's actually Swenson damn
it why did I never that he's he's
Alabama Swenson that's his real name
Alabama Swenson for those of you don't
know Svendsen is like the most common
generic last name in Sweden I would say
at least I don't know if that's actually
true but close enough 1720 1820 1920 own
know you know the rules and so do I
Veronica there is no that was a really
fun episode I really enjoy that Chad not
Veronica no love whatever her name was
20 years ago we opened our hearts in our
disgrace with the launch of play station
2 Xbox congratulations for 20 years guys
playstation shut the [ __ ] you know this
is fake because it doesn't show well I
know it's fake without but it they
didn't show when the tweet was made so
just a little giveaway I wish it was
real peace was never an option if brands
spoke to each other the way the way they
felt can you imagine if there was just
no level of professionalism in companies
that'd be so funny drawings made by
people with mental illness yep
that seems about right wait I can
finally share the one thing I'm good at
on this sub god damn alright I need to
make a yo-yo video and show this fool
that this air pod wearing fool that's
nothing
this is nothing just wait until I get I
need a little bit of practice and then
I'm gonna get you
this dog waited a full month only to be
forgotten rename the openly made fun of
for having a stupid name I never even
thought of the consequences for deep and
what he went through I'm sorry God as I
day but I alright the hair memes are
getting old we can stop it now you can
stop it you can stop the hair memes now
thank you thank you
pewds next theme is trebuchet this whole
separated yo your time well that
actually makes sense because next theme
I was gonna say it anyway
it's yo-yo next week's theme is yo-yo I
think it already happened yeah it
already happened gym leaders Felix and
March they would like to battle that's
such a cool fan art I really especially
like how you made my face just like 5
times wider than it is that that's
really cool I appreciate that thank you
I'm joking it's a great fan art I
appreciate thank you next time I'm going
through the barber and I'm showing them
a picture of this ok alright you got me
I did it I did the meme at least my
beard looks better now that's something
that's something to be happy about
reasons to be happy
nothing nothing Felix beard looks better
now thank you
smash that I'm sorry
it had to be done and it had to be done
I look at more hair memes
it's Joe Joe and hair memes that's all
we got this so far I blow dried my hair
today do you guys like it
Oh bye they watch this normal fast damn
I miss I miss being able to go fast I
really really miss they sucks that I
can't no it's all about my hair
is there anything not about my hair in
here ok I get it
look like M&Ms Bad's offspring son I
look like Eminem made his minecraft dog
have sex with his son that's what I look
like Felix they made a baby I cursed me
and my god dammit I didn't mean to I
have to get an apology to myself I don't
think that's how it works that's
definitely a lot how it works
let me check what people are saying in
the comments Felix I made the greatest
mistakes
my parents impossible suddenly my views
in Alabama just skyrocket they just went
up so much I don't know why everyone
freaking out about Sven freaking it Oh
Oh No Bengt where is he oh no it keeps
getting markers it keeps adding words
when you left Japan but Japan stayed you
think you're so clever don't you
congratulations you did it goddamnit I
looked okay I looked it doesn't have
that anymore it's cuz I it's cuz I have
the headphones I wear the headphones and
then my hair gets stuck okay it's the
headphones fault actually anything
related to my headphone say it's the
headphones fault I mean my hair what'd I
just say that's a great meme where's
this from
that's big peepee right there out boat
very nice it's giving me Oh you look
it's hair meme again
that's so funny I'm dying of laughter
shuffle the only way to get to floor 71
is to keep hitting shuffle and get lucky
yeah what the hell how people see me how
my grandma sees me seems to buy a
current so that artwork is that it from
Minecraft it's actually based on a real
artwork that's pretty cool
stop I do not look like coconut take
this back and apologize right in apology
right now oh my god alright at least
he's repping March I respect it that's
very respectable whoa okay what what is
even happening
alright just give me like half a day of
practice
easy easy when you're at half heart and
the two skeleton next to the spawner are
fighting each other I understand this
mean because I play minecraft if you
didn't laughs I'm sorry to say you're
not the gamer happy Women's Day Marzian
poppers Mario that's so sweet
why is Marcel wearing spaghetti what's
up with that cringe Felix elaborate the
fetus meat that elaborate means I really
does sing that way I can never wait Hey
look I'm Tyler one look at that it
finally happened guys oh that's so cute
I love it
that's so sweet if you got the turkey
merch that's very nice whoever did that
blue bandana cute this is what I get
though this is my level April 2020
spoilers okay true ok true alright look
forward to that one
oh come on yeah alright since about
accurate can you imagine the memes with
it when Godzilla comes can't wait
phone gamers aren't real gamers people
who play timber super pixel yeah those
are obviously an exception if your phone
gamer and you don't play tuber simulator
then don't even call yourself a gamer
don't you're naughty
the person you're dead to me you're a
bug man what's the most important organ
in the body brain brain baby pig face
good name
big beeping I will upload good meme what
if brain is making you think that brain
is more important that brain is as a way
to downplay the important things of
other organs maybe the brain is another
part of our body I can't believe I just
said that Finn is always asking where
it's Perry but never asked how is Perry
small peepee don't understand it don't
care
imagine donating to an e girl pathetic
mr. face maybe it's my time doing a
donate to no I will never do that
because I'm not a simp piers uses light
mode let's convert him to the dark side
it's not like mode look hold on told you
told yourself like mode by the chair my
lost hair can we gather like for each
like my hair will grow it didn't work
guys it didn't work it's math really hit
the applesauce big pp mean that made me
laugh that's funny trebuchet week it
finally happened trebuchet week everyone
doubted it would be true but it's
finally trebuchet week that's him that's
the guy who has very long PP all right
you're right big PP right there you're
welcome all right boys we're doing the
ultimate rickroll we're making this the
most liked video then we recrawl youtube
that's such a dumb meme but I'm 100%
aboard my aunt all my kids are so unique
her kids alright I got it I got it and
got it
funny we do look awfully a lot alike
like if I shave my beard I fit right in
I'd fit right in not good no not the
random shape event yeah it started in
Uganda and it ends in Africa I mean oh
god this is live footage guys alright
you need to stock up immediately
cup on all the food this is it it's over
big time if the random shrimp event has
begun there's not even the point of
preparing cannibalism it's gonna have to
come back there's no hope for humanity
if you haven't stocked up with at least
500 toilet paper rolls don't even think
that you're gonna survive that random
shrimp event if you don't have at least
20 different assault rifles ready to
defend yourself you're gone you're gone
making memes on Photoshop making memes
on paint making memes on Google
slideshow making memes on my birthday
cakes congratulations you did it you're
a absolute pathetic reddit user I'm just
kidding that was a little meaner than I
meant it was just an ironic joke and now
I feel bad happy birthday
that always died earlier than wellman
awesome it's not fair it's not fake it's
our testosterone that kill says okay not
epic pills in the next law I shouldn't
have done that
should not have done that you're right I
should not have done that
thank you Hagrid there it is ah what a
missed opportunity I'll bill it next
time and a giant yo-yo where should i
bill yo-yo top comment wins a yo-yo
smash like on this video to win the
yo-yo I'm not gonna give out the yo-yo
the classmate my brother were the
unconnected good meme comeback by 2020
it will be the best year ever
lawyer I love this meme so good I don't
know who that is
oh my god I'm sorry guys that's that's
that's so cringe of course I know who
that is
it's a Steve next name imagine simple
for a freaking girl with dyed hair
Marcia Felix its Hong Kong free yet to
me from Hong Kong no I don't think so
keep trying keep keep going Meredith
thank you thank you thank you pinging
with babish thank you dr. Phil is dr.
Phil making tik toks
to big baby dr. Phil congratulations
very nice that's hilarious
so tick-tock it's like very creative no
same energy there it is you versus the
guy will tell you not to worry about
very nice I know the world is gonna have
some spare time now that everyone is at
home quarantine download Peter Piper
pick slings it's the best way to spend
your time it will be like epic holiday
today here's the 69th day of the decade
nice nice that's good news
Hey look at that good news good news
everyone we did it congratulations thank
you for watching another episode of
what's the new intro sorry I wanted to
see what works here it's only right
celebrate that with Smith Effy nice
alright sorry I need to end this episode
here thank you for watching if you want
to check out the March that's great with
sports channel I appreciate it and I see
you guys tomorrow bye see you then hey
subscribe
you know what big peepees do they play
PewDiePie's pixel ings of course pixel
ings
is a creature collecting game I'm the
primary shareholder over a bazillion
players have downloaded and it's got a
perfect score it's safe to say it's the
most popular game of all time
PewDiePie pick slings it's awesome deal
with it
build with it
[Music]